[Music]
our minds extend far beyond our brains
through fields so there's reality but
there's the way reality appears to you
perhaps we make sense of the world
because the world is mind-like or even
internal to our minds experience is
basically what it's like to have
a mind
[Music]
think about who is it what is it that's
making sense of the world these little
pinprick bouncers otherwise known to our
head appear to have true things to say
about universe now let's look it's a
rather unequal contest our heads have a
volume of about four liters
ish the universe
is four times 10 to the power 23 cubic
light years so it seems a fairly unequal
contest when one is trying to understand
the other
the most famous attempt to explain our
capacity to understand the world comes
from kant's immanuel kant's critique of
pure reason
the opposite view is that biology shaped
the mind to make sense of the world
naturalism his argument is the mind
imposes the spatial temporal structure
of the experienced world the world is
like it is because it has
the categories of of the the forms of
sensible intuition he called it imposed
on the world
so it is the mind that brings the chaos
of experience to order by imposing the
categories of understanding such as
things like causation and so on so we
might say well if we impose these things
on the world what about the world in
itself he says the reality of the world
beyond experience is unknown to us so
the world makes sense to us because in
some fundamental sense we impose sense
on the world now the alternative is that
the mind conforms to nature because it
better bloody had to that is to say we
have to get things right otherwise we
would not have survived the very fact
that i'm up here talking to indicates
that i'm survivor who somehow must have
got the world right because if i didn't
get the world right i
wouldn't be around
we wouldn't survive
the mind is the alter the argument goes
it's really the brain
and the brain is an evolved organ that's
necessary for the kind of evolutionary
success that's produced its finest
product like me
so biology shaped the mind to make sense
of the world that's the naturalistic
viewpoint one of the extraordinary
things about our capacity to understand
the world is that we escape our
subjectivity the ultimate
aim of science is the so-called view
from nowhere and the close to the view
from nowhere something like e equals m c
squared
and e equals m c squared as it were has
escaped from subjective perspective it's
escaped from
my viewpoint your viewpoint it's escaped
uh from
frames of reference etc it is an eternal
truth
it's it's not it is one of those truths
that is not in any sense uh person
dependent
and that brings us to the mystery of the
nature of objective knowledge
how is it that we arrive at objective
knowledge knowledge that doesn't belong
to you or to me unlike our perceptions
under like our sensations my pain is my
pain but the theory of pain belongs to
any of us the trouble with that is that
it leaves a kind of senselessness at the
heart of sense and i'll mention that in
due course and finally the question we
want to ask is don't think we
wanted to
think about understanding the world
how do we have any sense of progress
is the world such that we could have a
complete understanding of it well what
would an under complete understanding be
well let's think about vision
supposing i could see all of the world
in order to see all of the world i'd
have to see through everything to see
everything else
so a totally comprehended world would
actually have no content it would just
be invisible just like a totally visible
world would be invisible
knowledge of course is ultimately based
on experience if i know that london is
200 miles from stockport that knowledge
ultimately can be tested against
experience
but knowledge transcends experience
again it's not something like a pain or
whatever that i um
that belongs to me
knowing that
something is the case is quite different
from experiencing something
and this brings us to a mystery and you
may think there's facts about the boring
the most boring things that are there's
nothing matter of fact about facts the
fact that we know that something is the
case you know it i know it we can share
it between us is one of those things
that is absolutely unique to humanity
[Music]
the sky when you look at it is inside
your head your skulls beyond the sky
this is just a virtual skull created as
a perceptual illusion
all your experience is inside your head
that is the conventional orthodox point
of view when you think it through of
course when you think it through it
seems absurd but that is nevertheless
what's being taught in all our
universities and philosophy departments
most philosophers are materialists and
almost all uh brain sciences and
neuroscience are based on the
materialist model
well
it's very counter-intuitive to believe
that it's not at all common sense and
i'd like to suggest an alternative
theory of vision which is so simple it's
hard to grasp
and that is that your image of me isn't
inside your head it's right here exactly
where it seems to be
um it's not inside your head it's in
your mind but not inside your brain
so i'm suggesting vision involves a
two-way process the inward movement of
light and the outward projection of
images
your images are projected out to where
they seem to be
if you look at a distant star
your mind stretches out over literally
astronomical distances and intriguingly
moves
years back in time because that light's
taken years to get here um and to
contact that star
when i look at you
my mind reaches out to touch you my
image of you is projected to where you
are
sometimes we project images to where
things aren't and that's an illusion or
a hallucination fortunately they're rare
if they were more common none of us
would have got here this evening we
would be bumping into things and we'd be
quite incapable of living in the world
so um most of the time we project out a
perceptual world and this vision uh
involves an inward movement of light
changes in the brain and then this
outward projection of images
now this is not an original theory of
vision i claim no
uh priority for this it's what
most people throughout the world have
always believed it's what plato believed
in his theory of vision it's what the
great greek geometer euclid believed and
it was euclid who thought in terms of
the projections coming out of the eyes
who was the first person to give a clear
explanation of mirror images
euclid pointed out that when light comes
off a mirror the light's reflected by
the mirror but the light comes into your
eyes you project out the images but
because those projections are mental not
physical
they go through the mirror and produce
virtual images behind the mirror which
is why you see these virtual images in
mirrors they're your outward projections
just going straight through the mirror
it's a theory still taught in textbooks
today it was a brilliant explanation of
mirror images
now i'm a scientist not a philosopher
and so
if this is true it should be testable
experimentally
is it
if i'm what i'm saying is right just by
looking at something you may be able to
affect what you're looking at because
your mind reaches out to touch it and i
think it reaches out through what i call
perceptual fields these are fields of
perception our minds reach out through
fields all our visual world now is in
fields projected by our minds coming out
of our eyes
if i looked at you from behind and you
didn't know it was there and you
couldn't hear me maybe i'll look through
a window so you can't there's no sound
there's no smell i'm just looking at you
from behind could you tell you were
being looked at from behind
now as soon as you ask that question you
realize it's a common experience
most people have had the experience of
being looked at from behind surveys show
that the great majority of people have
had this experience in fact there's a
slight sex difference more women than
men have experienced being stared at and
more men than women have experienced
staring at others and making them turn
around
but
both men and women have experienced this
in the passive and the active mode most
men and women over 90 percent and
surveys show that over 90 percent of
children
are well aware of this too
i've given talks on this in primary
schools to eight and nine-year-olds and
when i ask the question almost every
hand goes up yes i've had that and they
start telling these stories they're very
aware of it
so these things are very well known
now do they really happen uh in spite
many of my scientific colleagues would
say of course not it's impossible the
minds inside the head they can't really
happen it's all just superstition it's
just credulity ordinary people
are just don't know they haven't been
educated about vision
and indeed in scientific journals in the
last 100 years between 1890 and 1985
there were only four published papers on
this phenomenon in the scientific
literature it's a totally taboo topic
because it ought not to happen
[Music]
the brain is a prediction machine
and that everything that we perceive
everything that we experience everything
that we do
is a kind of brain-based prediction
now just think about what it means to be
a brain for a minute and let's take
perception as this task of figuring out
what's out there in the world there you
are you're your brain you're locked
inside this bony skull
it's dark in there it's silent
all you've got to go on as a brain are
streams of electrical signals which are
only indirectly related to things in the
world whatever they may be
and from these noisy ambiguous uncertain
electrical signals the brain conjures
forth
a world full of things with positions
and properties how does it do that
the idea and this is an idea that goes
way back in science and in philosophy is
that it's a process of inference of some
kind so by inference i just mean the
brain is making its best guess
about what's out there based on
inherently uncertain noisy ambiguous
data the brain is combining its
expectations
expectations that you're not personally
aware of having that can be built deep
into the circuitry of the brain like
that light comes from above expectations
combines those with sensory data and
then
what you perceive this is the hypothesis
is the content of the brain's
predictions it's not a readout of the
sensory data
in neuroscience there's this idea of
predictive processing or predictive
coding as a way
how this might actually happen in the
brain and the idea is simply this that
the brain is continually generating
predictions about the causes of its
sensory signals like is it you know is
it an object is it what chiro is it is
it round is it rectangular or these
predictions about
you know at various levels of
description is the color stopping here
or is it part of a bigger object all
sorts of things
and
sensory data that comes in is is just
calibrating these predictions it's
updating them it's serving as prediction
error
so our brain's
perceptual content comes from the inside
out and it's just reigned in by sensory
data this is quite an inversion of how
we might typically think of it it's very
intuitive to think of perception as a
process of reading out what's already
there in the information that comes into
our senses
this is very different it's saying that
perceptual content essentially comes
from within it's always a construction
but it's calibrated it's geared to the
world it's tied to the world in useful
ways and critically not by a criterion
of accuracy the brain doesn't care
whether it's accurately or exhaustively
capturing reality it's just if it's
useful and we see colors we experience
colors not because
colors exist but because perceiving
colors is a very useful way
for the brain to guide behavior
and this is this is a radical shift that
that that and it's not my idea at all it
goes back to helmholtz and cans in some
ways that perception comes in this from
the inside out and so what we're doing
in my lab one of the things we're doing
and i'll go quickly through this is
trying to put these these ideas to the
test a little bit it's one thing to say
this but does it actually make sense in
terms of the data well one thing that
actually already makes sense of is we
know in the brain there are many more
connections that go in this inside out
direction than in the outside in
direction
this is kind of mysterious if you think
that perception is done more in the
outside in direction so it makes sense
from that perspective we've also done a
bunch of experiments trying to see
whether the brain's expectations
actually do shape
uh what we experience so some of these
experiments are very simple we just lead
people to do things like expect to see
a particular kind of image we cue them
to expect to see a house or a face and
then we show these houses and faces in
various
uh deliberately ambiguous situations
and we ask
how do these expectations affect
conscious perception and what we find is
that when people are expecting to see a
face
they see that face consciously more
quickly and more accurately than if it's
unexpected this is interesting in a
sense it's like people are used to
saying that you know i'll believe it
when i see it but actually it's the
other way around that you'll see it if
you believe it
[Music]
the mind the english word the mind does
not have an exact equivalent in
contemporary german in 18th century
german there was something which worked
almost like the english term the mind
gemud but no one uses this anymore and
it also doesn't mean the mind anymore to
the extent to which you would even use
it so the mind is not an obviously
referring term it's not like obviously
we know what the mind is and the
question is what its relation is its
relation to the brain we don't even know
exactly what the mind is apart from
meaning exceptions to the term that in
particular philosophers have offered so
the term the mind i think is an artifact
of
english-speaking philosophy and a
misguided one on top of that because
it's um
a consequence of trying to make sense of
nonsense okay it's part of a long
nonsense poem
the mind so i never really understood
what that is yeah there's a better term
in german so now i'm playing the german
philosopher and uh uh but uh but now i'm
giving sense to it okay so the the
better word is geist uh and a way of
translating this is roughly
human-mindedness so here's how this
works okay
so humans are in the peculiar situation
and we are all in this situation right
now together and in a self-conscious way
in the peculiar situation of wondering
how we blend in with non-human reality
so we know there's non-human reality at
least i don't doubt it and non-human
reality includes you know like
galaxies and
forces i happen to think it includes
numbers but be that as it may whatever
is part of non-human reality something
is right
now here's my definition now of human
mindedness
human-mindedness
is the capacity
to lead the life
in light of your answer to the question
how you blend in
okay so
human mindedness
is the capacity to lead a life
in light of your answer to the question
how you blend in
now this let me give you a example of
this so imagine you believe you have an
immortal soul
then you will do certain things
so imagine you have an immortal soul and
you think god is constantly observing
you so if you think you have an immortal
soul and your thoughts are you know
attested by god are there good thoughts
right does he want to eat sausage does
he want to have sex and so on and you're
constantly trying to hide your thoughts
but it doesn't quite work and so so
you'll act in a certain way all i'm
saying is that if you think
okay your way to blend in is to have an
immortal soul in a divine plan then
you'll act in a certain way
now let's imagine an extreme denier of
this let's call this fictitious person
richard dawkins okay
so now you have someone who says no
absolutely no to that right
i am just a sophisticated killer ape
trying to spread his genes
so a good way to do this is become
professor of biology at oxford and write
popular books which will hopefully
hopefully attract some mating partners
so
so if that's what you believe right then
you'll act in different ways i don't
want to spell out what this entails and
what the best way then of you know
carrying out your plan would be but you
see you'll do different things
now the important fact about human
mindedness is the following
regardless of the truth or falsity of
your account of how you blend in
you will become different
you can change the way you are
by having false beliefs about yourself
if i have a true belief about myself i
also change i might become enlightened
now that case differs substantially from
the case of say the mass of overall mass
of fermions in the known universe
regardless of my true or false belief
about it they are just facts of the
matter and they don't change
in virtue of my false beliefs about them
okay so i clearly have false beliefs
about fermions i'm not a physicist i
know some things about fermions if you
push me a little bit you'll notice that
i clearly have some false beliefs about
them actually everyone has false beliefs
about fermions because we haven't fully
figured them out but be that as it may
okay my false beliefs about them
don't change them the human mind is
precisely this
living a life
in light of your conception of who or
what you are
[Music]
so you were
talking about experience as subjective
and conscious
does that suggest or not that there can
still be things that are mysterious in
it can you have can you be fully
conscious of something which remains
mysterious
yeah well i think in some sense
consciousness experience is the thing
which we know more directly than we know
anything in the world i certainly seem
to have very direct and immediate
knowledge of my experience my visual
experience right now
feeling of pain and so on but still have
a level of understanding
and explanation i think it's extremely
mysterious so i would uh
i would prefer to
raise these questions in the key of
explanation i mean i agree with peter
that if you ask the question is
experiencing part of the material world
it's
at the very least ambiguous and unclear
uh what the content of that is for me
the the real question is how can we
explain
experience the experiences we have and
the fact that we're
experiencing now and in particular if
you're going to
raise that in the key of science can you
explain that experiencing in physical
terms let me stop you right on that you
say what you're experiencing now what
are you experiencing now
many things i'm experiencing a a certain
feeling in the in the bottom of my of my
foot and my bum on the on the seat i'm
experiencing
i'm seeing you right now i'm having a
visual experience with you and of the
floor and of my hand i'm hearing the
sound of my own voice droning on and on
and what's the what's the problem with
any of that if any
why is there any such thing why is there
any experience how and in particular
can any of that be explained in holy
physical terms the natural place to look
is in terms of my brain there's a whole
bunch of processes in my brain and you
can tell quite a lot for example about
the process whereby the eye sends
signals to the visual cortex which sends
signals throughout the brain but does
any of that explain
why it is that i'm in fact visually
experiencing that there's a certain
subjective quality from the first person
so you can say that it's the case we
can't say why it's the case
that's right yeah um at least certain
kinds of explanation those in terms of
neuroscience for example seem at least
to be those wholly in terms of
neuroscience seem to be incomplete that
these are from whether there are other
explanations maybe there are historical
or psychological explanations i'm
experiencing this because i looked over
there and uh
and there you were and of course i saw
you but that's kind of presupposing that
i have the capacity for experience the
very fact of it in the first place is
not explained
and let's pick up on this notion that uh
you know
uh the explanations of neuroscience are
incomplete because it clearly goes back
to what you were saying earlier susanna
and i i think what you were saying is
well yes the explanations of
neuroscience might be incomplete right
now because neuroscience has a bit
further to go
but in principle neuroscience could
explain everything and that would be is
that something you would
continue to disagree with even if
susanna and her discipline were to
evolve to a point where neuroscience
could no longer be perfected anymore
would it be for you the case david that
you'd say that's still an
insufficient explanation we cannot
we cannot explain all of experience in
neuroscientific terms i'm actually i'm a
big fan of neuroscience i'm a big fan of
the neuroscience of consciousness which
suzanne has contributed a lot too but i
think at least at the moment and maybe
in principle
it's got certain limitations which is
it's basically a science of correlations
we find out the uh for example the
processes in the brain which are active
when someone's having experience say of
a certain color or of a certain shape or
a certain going on
in their um
in their
visual field and it's up a level really
the science at least recently has been a
level of correlations the project has
been to look for the neural correlative
consciousness or the ncc as some people
talk of which has nice star trek
overtones for those of you who remember
the enterprise it was ncc 1701
looking for the neural correlate of
consciousness we're talking what we want
to get to is explanation and i think
my view is that
really what we need to do is the
neuroscience is always going to
it's great for explaining certain things
behaviors and functional responses
things on the objective side but to get
to the objective side i think somehow
you need to assume some kind of bridging
principle that links you from the
objective to the subjective and if you
do that and people have got some
interesting proposals out there right
now including neuroscientists who have
theories that link neuroscience to the
subjective then neuroscience plus such a
bridging principle might give you some
explanation of consciousness but
neuroscience on its own i think is not
going to do it
[Music]
in the context of decision making and of
consciousness
we do have this remarkable thing that we
call self-control
and it's often very robust it's often
very non-conscious in its execution
it involves skills that can be technical
social
wide
ranging life skills skills about how to
handle your finances how to handle
matters concerning health
it involves such things as maintaining a
goal despite distractions or despite
other other impulses
it involves suppressing impulses that
are inconsistent with maintaining a goal
delaying gratification it involves
adhering to training these are all
things that we
know
at a very common sense level and what
we're learning now
is that
uh maintaining a goal often you have to
be conscious to do it
but the mechanisms whereby it is
achieved are largely
non-conscious
and so
there are many things that uh we learn
as skills sometimes we learn them just
through experience
of having things work out well or having
other things work out badly
we also learn through imitation we learn
through approval and disapproval from
parents and siblings and teachers we
learn through stories and songs
and simply watching others so i've
emphasized that these these skills are
are important and clever and appropriate
but that in the execution of a
well-known skill
uh there really isn't time for conscious
deliberation and for consideration of
salience
sometimes of course um
we give in to impulse
and uh sometimes
the negative feedback is sufficient that
that impulse gets squashed uh and we
don't do it again the key structures
shown here are the ventral tegmental
area
and the ventral tegmental area projects
to a nucleus not shown here
the nucleus accumbens and it projects to
the nucleus accumbens and
um secretes dopamine
and those neurons then activate neurons
in the nucleus accumbens where if
the action produce good consequences
uh
endocannabinoids are released it feels
pleasurable so it's not the dopamine per
se that feels pleasurable it's the
interaction with the
neurons in the nucleus accumbens
and other neurons if the outcome of the
action was negative and painful
other neurons will respond and
indicate that uh this action is not a
good action um to do again in other
words it will give it negative valuation
and those are neurons that are mostly
involved um
with serotonin
so you can see in the case of serotonin
there is widespread projection
not only within cortex but in these more
ancient structures uh within the the
brain stem
this is not a terribly illuminating um
diagram but it conveys this is a a
diagram of a rat brain not a human brain
but it indicates that in these older
structures
there are a lot of interactions between
the vta the ventral tegmental area which
is the dopamine releasing area the
nucleus accumbens which releases
endocannabinoids and opioids but many
other structures as well and that's why
the skill learning
gets more and more and more complex
the more complex uh the nature of the
brain uh as as a whole
but it is remarkable that even
rats for example as well as as foxes and
and wolves
can display really quite impressive
self-control and of course what we're
interested in also
is
where those mechanisms differ in
individuals who really lack self-control
and how self-control
through behavioral techniques for
example might be modified so that
individuals have more control
over their specific impulses
[Music]
so you've mostly heard about the hard
problem of consciousness this very deep
mystery one common reaction people have
is to say okay let's just put the hard
problem of consciousness on one side
that's too difficult
what we can do is focus on the
quote-unquote easier problem of tracking
the neural correlates of consciousness
the ncc
working out what kinds of brain activity
correspond to what kinds of conscious
experience now so towards the end of the
1990s the neuroscientist christophe [ __ ]
pictured here had a bet with david
chalmers
he bet him a case of fine wine that in
25 years we would have completely mapped
out the neural correlates of
consciousness
it looks like he's about to lose that
bet because you know it's a mess we've
got lots of different theories
different views about whether
consciousness is in the front of the
brain or the back of the brain
very little way of thinking how we can
make consensus here and i think the
problem at the core of this is that
consciousness is not publicly observable
you can't look inside somebody's head
and see their feelings and experiences
so to do the science you have what we
have to have is what i call detection
procedures we have to have principles
that link
observable behavior
to conscious unobservable conscious
experience so here's one of them
the rep what i call the report principle
that if a subject has an experience they
can report it
so once if you accept that principle
then we can see how you can do some
neuroscience how you can track the
neural correlates because you want to
know if someone's having an experience
ask them
trouble is all these detection
procedures are controversial
so some people many people like um ned
block for example accept what's coming
i'm known as the overflow thesis that
there are experiences that we are unable
to attend to
how do you why would anyone think
they're experiences you're unable to
attend to
well there's you know it's quite well
established now that there are
significant limits on how much we're
able to attend to at one time you know i
can't attend to the details of all of
your faces
and the sounds outside and the clothes
on my body at the same time so what do
you do with that you go two ways some
people say
well i'm not actually experiencing the
details of your faces all i'm really ex
consciously experiencing is what i can
attend to whereas other philosophers say
no i am actually experiencing all the
intricate detail of your faces and the
feeling of the clothes on my body and
the sounds outside it's just
i'm limited on what i can attend to in
my experience so then you're going to
have the result that there are some
things you're actually experiencing it's
part of your conscious experience but
you can't attend to it and then we start
to get exceptions to the report
principle and this isn't just an
abstract philosophical debate
this leads to very different theories of
the neuroscience the neural correlates
of consciousness so this isn't the hard
problem this was supposed to be the easy
problem
so if like pacquan lao pictured here you
accept the report principle then you're
going to tend to locate consciousness in
the front of the brain if you deny it
like ned block you're going to tend to
locate it at the back of the brain
why is that because those who accept the
report principle there is a tight
connection between something being
conscious
and it being available for cognition and
the prefrontal cortex the front of the
brain is responsible for cognitive
processes like working memory
so there's just this very deep
difficulty about how we do the science
now you know there are ways of
responding to this and having kind of
indirect argument but it essentially
becomes philosophy metaphysics it's very
hard to see how we can do you know real
experimental science with this
however so i'm in i am inclined
to accept this strong emergentist view
on philosophical grounds i think it's an
open question empirically we don't know
enough about how the brain works to
establish it one way or another but on
philosophical grounds for example i'm i
can't go into this now but i'm
increasingly skeptical about a kind of
reductionist picture of rationality or
agency so i am inclined on philosophical
grounds
to accept this strong emergent as view
that there are
new fundamental entities systems level
properties in the brain if that turns
out to be true
uh then we have a possible way forward
on this deep difficulty that's been
going on for about 150 years there's a
great paper by matthias michelle
arguing how we've been having this
dispute
over like the report principle since the
19th century okay but if strong
immersionism is true then identifying
strongly emergent causal dynamics will
be a major piece of evidence in
establishing the neural correlates of
consciousness if it turns out for
example that there are strongly emergent
dynamics in the back of the brain but
not in the front of the brain that is to
say there are causal dynamics that are
not reducible to underlying chemistry or
physics
that will be a very strong experimental
reason to locate consciousness there and
this isn't just a sort of abstract
possibility
there are people engaged in this martin
picard in the mitochondrial
psychobiology lab at columbia university
is exploring experimentally the
hypothesis that mitochondria in the
brain form social networks and we should
understand their behavior not by
reducing it to underlying chemistry but
as kind of irreducible social networks
the neuroscientist kevin mitchell who is
not a fan of pan psychism very hostile
to found psychism but
does believe in some kind of and that
strongly emergent dynamics in the brain
and is exploring ways of modeling them
so these seem to be the most exciting
ways forward
on the science of consciousness now i
don't think you know
this doesn't necessarily entail pansysm
i think you know because consciousness
is not publicly observable
i don't think you can ever
totally pin down a theory of
consciousness
with experiments
um
i so i i think if so if it were
established as i tentatively think it
will one day be that there is strong
emergence in the brain that leaves open
to philosophical possibilities
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
[Music]